good morning I'm Michael Stanislawski
chair of contemporary civilizations and
it's really delight for me to welcome
you all here on this beautiful morning
when and you have know that it's more
important to hear but lock than to play
outside in the sunshine but more
seriously to introduce to you our
speaker for this morning prezzo Jeremy
Waldron presser Waldron is university
professor and professor of law at NYU a
position he has held since 2006 he has
recently been elected to the cheat le
chair of social and political theory at
all souls college at Oxford position he
will hold jointly with his nyu position
beginning in 2011 as you might discern
when he starts his top rest of what
Waldron was born in New Zealand and he
was educated in law and philosophy both
at in New Zealand and at Oxford his
career has included academic
appointments at Edinburgh Berkeley
Princeton at Columbia University for
from 1996 to 2006 and then downtown at
NYU he delivered the homes lectures at
Harvard on hate speech in fall of 2009
the Tanner lectures on human dignity at
Berkeley in the spring of 2009 and the
stores lectures on the citation of
foreign law at Yale in 2007 he's the
author of many books I won't read the
whole list but his books include the
right to private property something that
block had something to say about liberal
rights the dignity of legislation law
and disagreement a book directly on
related to today's subject god lock and
equality and most recently a book
entitled tortured terror and trade-off
philosophy for the White House he's the
author of more than a hundred published
articles and essays and legal and
political philosophy both contemporary
and historical he's particularly
well-known
as an expert on on issues such as
homelessness judicial review the rule of
law democracy and constitutionalism on
minority cultural rights and historical
injustice and cosmopolitanism and on
torture and security issues his
publications in the history of ideas are
also well known particularly and that is
why I invited him to come to speak to us
today on the political philosophy of
John Locke so as you discerned from the
announcement for this lecture the the
title of the talk is an intriguing one
the mother to have her title John Locke
on motherhood and equality and so I
introduced to you professor Jeremy
Waldron
good morning it's wonderful to be back
at Columbia I know that you haven't
reached John luck in your studies in
this course so far but you know who he
is I think you're writing in the late
7th in the second half of the 17th
century famous for his two treatises of
government famous for his essay
concerning human understanding and it's
of the two treatises of government that
I'm going to talk this morning about
this particular theme of motherhood and
its bearing on lock's apprehensions of
the rights of women and of equality
between men and women so let's begin the
mother to have her title of all the
reasons that are cited over the ages to
condemn women to a position of
inferiority motherhood including the
disabilities of pregnancy and the
socially imposed obligations of
child-rearing motherhood is the most
prominent true motherhood can be a
status that is held in high esteem you
can think of the order of socialist or
Soviet motherhood or you can think of
the revered status of the Blessed Virgin
Mary Mother of God but that high esteem
hardly ever generates affirmative
consequences for political power or for
social Authority when motherhood is
mentioned what we expect to see is women
relegated to a sphere in which any high
esteem accorded to this biological and
social function is politically
inconsequential motherhood is either too
important to be contaminated with
politics or to debilitating to allow for
the possibility of authority and
participation motherhood in our
tradition usually equals subordination
the philosopher whose work I want to
talk about today is an exception to this
rule for John Locke who lived and wrote
in England and the second half of the
1600s
motherhood was not an obstacle but the
key to women's equality so long as he
talks just about women and their
comparative standing with men locks
position on equality is ambivalent and
partly reflective of contemporary
prejudice but when he turns to
motherhood all that changes it's in his
talk of motherhood that lock is at his
most radical it's when he turns his
attention to the political rights and
titles of mothers that we find him at
his most aggressively egalitarian on
matters of gender and that's so much
opposite to what we would expect that
I've made it the focus of a whole
argument today it's certainly not a
position accepted by everybody who
studies John Locke it's not accepted by
most feminists who have devoted time to
his work the best known example is the
work of the Australian political
philosopher she teaches at UCLA Carol
Pateman in her book the sexual contract
which is a fine piece of writing but I'm
going to argue that there is very little
basis and locks writings for the
interpretation of his work put forward
by Professor Pateman certainly lock was
inconsistent on the issue of women's
status women's equality and women's
rights some of what he said was radical
and egalitarian some of what he said as
I mentioned before reflected
contemporary prejudice so you've got
kind of two sides and we have to make a
decision which was the real lock which
was locks true views on questions of
women and gender and equality I believe
there's no reason whatever to take the
prejudice as dominant and his remarkable
expressions of equality as hypocrisy as
though he was trying to pull the wool
over the eyes of his 18th century 17th
century English audience such
equivocation would be obviously
unmotivated the path to political
correctness in that era pointed in
exactly the opposite direction so the
officer conclusion may be the one we
should adopt lock did pay some lip
service to political correctness that is
too contemporary
against women but whenever it mattered
whenever anything hung on it whenever it
really amounted to anything in his
intellectual and political enterprise he
expressed himself very forcefully and at
length in favor of basic equality and it
was his views on motherhood that led the
charge in that in that regard John Locke
as Michael indicated has often been a
sort of obsession of mine five out of
the six first articles I ever published
were about John Locke that was back in
the late 1970's and early 80's and
almost 30 years later and seven more
articles and one and a half books later
I still find myself unable to shake free
of him he's a he's a frustrating figure
because in many ways he's seen as dull
moderate liberal respectable in fact he
was revolutionary regice idol in his the
conspiracies he entered into and fled
from Oxford in 1683 with his books
burning behind him not to return until
after the king who had orders his
expulsion from christ church college was
overthrown in recent years I have
focused my attention unlocks neglected
first treatise you know the two
treatises of government the first of his
two treatises of government or rather
the half of the first treatise that we
actually have will say a little bit more
about that in a moment the second
treatise is what everybody reads in
college it's what you will read when you
study locked in a few months it's a
second treatise that was massively
influential a hundred years later as the
philosophical background for the
Declaration of Independence for the
American Revolution and for much of the
framing of the United States
Constitution the second treatise is
where lock sets out his affirmative
theory in his own voice of government
political equality natural rights social
contract rejection of absolutism
government by consent the defence of
private property the rule of law the
separation of power
hours and the right of resistance and
revolution that's the second treatise
the first treatise by contrast is
negative and polemical it's aimed
theories of the Divine Right of Kings
and aimed at one particular theory that
of Robert filmer that's a film as a
movies filmer who believed that film I
believe that if you studied Scripture
you would see that equality was false
and that God had authorized absolute
monarchy filmer believed that the
authority of kings was prefigured in the
rule of Adam over the whole of creation
in the rule of Adam in particular / eve
in the rule of Adam over as children and
in general of husbands over their wives
fathers over their children kings as
absolute parents over their abject and
divinely subordinated subjects and there
was some attempt in filmers work and and
in royalist rhetoric and the 1670s to
1680s to say that somehow this mantle
that God had conferred on Adam had now
floated down the ages to rest on the
shoulders of Charles the second and his
brother James the second of England
filmer was a sort of biblical
fundamentalist and lock thought his
works efficiently dangerous and likely
in the late sixteen 70s and early 1680s
to be sufficiently influential to
justify devoting a couple hundred pages
to a refutation chapter and verse of its
alleged foundation in Scripture filmers
work written in the 1660s had been
revived in the political crisis about
succession to the throne at the
beginning of the 1680s and was apparent
to John Locke and to his political
cronies that it demanded an answer not
because it was inherently persuasive but
rather because it was intellectually
pernicious and politically dangerous
exercising and influence out of all
proportion to its cojen see much of
filmers case could be answered just by
developing a more plausible alternative
affirmative theory of politics and
that's what happened in the Second
Treatise but in the first treatise the
the reckoning was that the scriptural
side of filmers case needed to be
cleared away so the good lib
political theory could be built up in
the space that was left so the first
treatise was written probably in the
early 1680s published eventually 1688
1689 sometime in that intervening eight
years lock lost half the manuscript who
knows when probably when he fled to
Holland in 1683 he lost it he didn't
bother to replace or rewrite it or even
to provide the remaining bits of the
first treatise with the proper ending it
actually just breaks off in the middle
of a sentence presumably where a
manuscript reached the bottom of the
page and you see this I've given you a
sort of a song sheet here so you can
sing along with some of the Loch Lochy
and passages but you'll see in passage
number one lock telling his reader at
the beginning of the work Rita thou hast
here the beginning and the end of a
discourse concerning government the
beginning means the first half of the
first treatise the end means the whole
of the Second Treatise thou hast here
the beginning and end of a discourse
concerning government what phases
otherwise disposed of the papers that
should have filled up the middle and
we're more than all the rest it is not
worthwhile to tell thee I guess it's
possible that this stuff is lying around
in a closet somewhere and one of these
days it will surface in cambridge or an
Oxford or in Leiden or come up on eBay
and that's a prospect that makes us lock
scholars wake up screaming in the middle
of the night we have to spend the rest
of our lives trying to figure out the
second half of the first treatise but
finding the missing pages might not make
that much difference most of us no
longer view the Bible as a source of
political legitimacy and so carrying on
with the tedious refutation of film may
not seem particularly important we dip
into the first treatise from time to
time political theorists do but we're
not really interested in the biblical
case that life is making it's hard to
read how to follow probably not worth
the candle and political philosophers as
opposed to theorists don't study it at
all they take their agenda for liberal
political philosophy entirely from the
Second Treatise it barely occurs to them
that there is a first as well the only
people who really read at a historian's
of ideas who do it to annoy the
philosophy
I actually think there is a substantial
body of political theory to be distilled
from the first treatise and the work I'm
presenting today is part of the
firstfruits of the Waldron first
treatise distillery there's a tremendous
amount there on the theory of property
there's a particularly a whole theory of
inheritance which the Second Treatise
lacks there's an extremely interesting
hermeneutics on how to read scripture
disposing a filmers interpretive
approach not least the whole thing the
120 pages that we have amounts to a
sustained display of the analytics of
political argument as Locke tries to
show us how to argue and using filmer as
a deplorable paradigm how not to argue
in political philosophy he shows as
readers what the difference is between
argument and assertion and the
importance of keeping different lines of
argument straight so that their
respective consequences can be traced
and compared to one another it's really
one of the earliest examples we have in
the Canon of a book-length dissection of
another person's book-length argument a
critique whose analytic standards are
perfectly familiar to us but above all
and this is the most interesting thing
the first treatise is really a long
disquisition on equality as lock sets
out to refute root-and-branch filmers
claim and just that a quote from filmer
this is not on your song sheet film has
claimed that there there cannot be any
multitude of men but that in it there is
one person among them that hath the
right to be the king of all the rest for
any group of people who ever there's one
person who is sufficiently closely
related to Adam to be king of all the
rest lock confronts us and he's unable
to confront it without confronting the
central premises of one of us one of the
central premises are filmers account
that women are naturally subordinate to
men because Eve was divinely
subordinated to Adam and for that reason
according to film our mothers have much
less authority over their children and
their fathers and I think this actually
is worth studying for us because we are
not free of people who claim
a warrant in scripture for ascribing
women to a subordinate position in view
of motherhood it's not that our views
about motherhood and women are going to
be hostage to what was written in the
seventeenth century by some Englishmen
although lock has been very influential
including in this country there's a fine
account of his influence in New England
in a book by Mary Beth Norton called
founding mothers gendered power and the
forming of American society and the
factors that locks constitutional theory
was part of the oxygen that fed the
flames of the American Revolution and
the founding of the Constitution it may
not have been foreground and say the
federalist papers as Montesquieu's work
was but it's deep brackla and deep and
pervasive background and you can see it
sometimes word-for-word in the
formulations particularly of Jefferson's
Declaration of Independence you know
that the 1776 Declaration of
Independence opened with the famous
earth-shattering words we hold these
truths to be self-evident that all men
are created equal that they are endowed
by their creator with certain
unalienable rights all men are created
equal that's Jefferson's claim and locks
claim what does it mean when we say all
men we can read the phrase inclusively
or exclusively inclusively can mean all
males exclusively can mean all members
of the human species and the fact is
that these issues arise for Locke as
well as they arise for Jefferson all men
says locker by nature equal well does he
mean all man or all men which one which
inclusive or exclusive does he have in
mind I mentioned carol paton man's book
and carol pateman says this she says it
is very clear that women are excluded
from the status of individual in the
natural condition the state of nature
Locke argues that the attributes of
individuals are sexually differentiated
only men naturally have the
characteristics of free and
beings women are naturally subordinate
to men women are not free and equal
individuals but natural subjects so she
assumes that when lot talks about this
equality of man by nature he must mean
men in the narrower sense males Susan
oaken however observed that lock went
back and forth in the way that he used
the word man and man sometimes in one
passage he talked about men restricting
their carnal knowledge of women to one
woman in a lifetime that's obviously a
reference to males it doesn't make sense
apart from that but in passage number
two on the song sheet I've indicated in
a piece from the essay concerning
understanding that when locke talks
about the way children learn the meaning
of the word man he says that they
generalize from nurse and mother and
father and from any complex idea they
had of Peter and James Mary and Jane
that's a more accommodating account of
how a man can acquire a gender neutral
meaning the decisive point is that lock
actually confronts the two possible
readings in the first treatise and asks
himself explicitly the same question
that we are asking and when he does that
he firmly and explicitly and
unequivocally adopts the inclusive
reading it's a remarkable passage this
is going to be passage three and four
understandably neglected by Professor
Pateman and others who support the
interpretation of lock as a sexist it's
a passage where lock is talking about
God's giving man dominion over the world
in Genesis God blessed them and said to
them be fruitful and increase in number
fill the earth and subdue it rule over
the fish in the sea and the birds in the
sky and over every living creature that
moves on the ground God had created man
in his own image and gave them this
dominion over nature filmer claimed this
as the basis of Adam's right to rule but
Locke said it depends how you read the
word man and it depends how you read the
pronoun them and him and so if you have
a look at reading number three
whatever God gave by the words of this
grant it was not to Adam in particular
exclusive of all other men whatever
Dominion he had thereby it was a
Dominion in common with the rest of
mankind that this donation was not made
in particular to Adam appears evidently
from the words of the text of being made
to more than one for it was spoken in
the plural number god blessed them and
said unto them have dominion God says
unto Adam and Eve have dominion the
grant being to them spoken to Eve also
must not she thereby be lady as well as
he Lord of the world and in case there
is any doubt on the very next paragraph
and this is paragraph 4 on the reading
he says the word them and the text must
include the species of man and the 26
verse where God declares his intention
to give this Dominion it is plain that
he meant that he would make a species of
creatures that should have dominion over
the other species of this terrestrial
globe the words are and God said let us
make man in our image and let them have
dominion over the fish etc they then
were to have dominion who even those who
were to have the image of God the
individuals of that species of man that
he was going to make for them should
signify Adam singly exclusive of the
rest that should be in the world with
them is both against Scripture and all
reason it cannot possibly be made sense
if man and the former part of the verse
do not signify the same as them in the
latter man there as usual has taken for
the species and them the individuals of
the species and we have a reason in the
very text God makes him in his own image
after his own likeness makes him an
intellectual creature and so capable of
Dominion for wherein so ever else the
image of God consisted the intellectual
nature was certainly a part of it and
belonged to the whole species there's
just no way of reading those two
meditations on pronouns and words and
concluding that lock meant a narrow
exclusive masculine reading of the word
men you can't even conclude that he was
careless on the matter he approaches it
here more thoughtfully and a greater
length that others have done including
others of our generation it's a
fabulously important passage it's the
one place in the two treatises where
lock associates humankind and gin
with the judeo-christian notion of the
image of God in a way that makes it
absolutely clear that that
characterization applies to Eve as well
the only other member of the species
around to be included in them at the
time as well as to Adam two women as
well as men and applies to her as it
applies to him in virtue of her
intellectual nature so locks directly
confronting how to read pronouns how to
read this word man and giving us a
particular answer so that's a deep
philosophical passage on how to think
these matters through what's on the
other side what is Carol Pateman base
her reading on the most damning evidence
that she and others cite our locks
remarked again quite explicit about
domination in marriage its passage from
the Second Treatise although there are
hints of it to in the first locks
talking about marriage which he
understands as a contractual
relationship devoted to the nourishment
and upbringing of children it's a
relationship marriage as a relationship
which is necessary he says because the
mother of a young child is capable of
conceiving and is commonly with child
again long before the first child is out
of a dependency for support on his
parents how all this is set out in
paragraph 5 they're both there for the
father who is bound to take care for
those he hath begat is under an
obligation to continue in conjugal
society with the same woman longer than
with longer than other creatures are
whose young can subsist by themselves
before their mother acquires another
pregnancy so far so good but then in
passage 6 the notorious passage six lock
then goes on to say this about
disagreements and marriage this is the
evidence in favor of Carol Carol patrons
interpretation the husband and wife
though they have but one common concerns
the upbringing of the children yet
having different understandings will
unavoidably sometimes have different
wills to it therefore being necessary
that the last determination that is the
rule should be placed somewhere it
naturally falls to the man's share
the a blur and the stronger it naturally
falls to the man's share as the a blur
and the stronger there's the damage to
locks egalitarianism this is what Lauren
Clark called Glocks fundamental sexism
prominently and explicitly and inner
race ibly on display and it's there
somebody who's making the case that I'm
making has to come to terms with that
passage never mind that he does go on
immediately to mitigate what he said
about the husbands decisional Authority
saying that it affects only the things
of their common interest in property
leaving the wife and fallen true
position possession of what by
contractors her peculiar right never
mind that he goes on to say that the
wife has a Liberty to separate from her
husband where their natural right or
their contract allows it or the customs
or laws of the country they live in and
that the children upon such separation
fall to the father or mother's lot as
such contract does determine lot on
prenuptial agreements never mind all
those concessions in patrons view and in
many people's view the reference and
passage sex to the husband as the a blur
and stronger must mean that women are
not fully human that they cannot own
property that they cannot enter into
contracts and that they are not
fundamentally the equals of other human
beings and the whole point of the social
contract is to subordinate them that's
the pavement thesis based on that
explicit statement in passage 6 any
evidence to the contrary like the great
passage from the first treatise that I
quoted a few moments ago is dismissed
and ignored at best the idea is here in
passage sexes locks true colors all the
rest is locked trying to fool us luck
trying to put things over students like
yourselves trying to convince you that
liberalism supports women's rights
whereas in fact what he really thinks is
that man have the right to rule because
they're the a blur and the stronger as I
said before it's a mystery why lock
would have wanted to fool anybody in
why engage in such an elaborate charade
there was no particular incentive of
political correctness in the 1680s so
when your instructors tell you that lock
was really in favor of inequality just
hiding it ask them why was he hiding it
what did he have to gain from hiding it
on the contrary the appearance of gender
equality would cause a much more trouble
than the patriarchal ISM he's supposed
to be trying to disguise if flock were
really in favor of denying that women
qualified as men for the sake of basic
political equality why wouldn't he just
come out and say that his contemporaries
did Samuel puffins Dorf said states have
certainly been formed by men rather than
women and this is why the right of the
father prevails Lochte's own friend
james turrell in his attack on filmer
said that women are commonly unfit for
several business and terrell went on to
say there never was an e-government
where all the promiscuous rabble of
women and children had votes as not
being capable of it why would lock be
less forthcoming on this than his friend
if this is what he really really
believed I accept that the comments
about the husband being the a blur and
the strong stronger in passage sex are
disappointing so there is no consistent
position here we can't save locky
inequality by just saying what he
accepted the custom of his day locked
challenged the custom of his day on all
sorts of things and he was certainly
capable of challenging it on this
question of gender equality as well what
we can say is that he treats what he
says about the decisional power of
husbands as a matter of little
consequence he rests nothing on it so
far as marriage is concerned it's like
tossing a coin it's a tiebreaker because
decisions have to be made among two
people rather than three there has to be
a final word and marriage and so a
marginal difference of ability and
strength will do if and this is
important if no contrary arrangement has
been made between husband and wife
husband and wife can contract to have
the woman having the final say for
example what really happens is that lock
is being purely defensive here rebutting
the charge that his fundamental eager
arianism undermines all structures of
decision and order the so this what I
want to say is there's no reason to
leverage passage six into a general
denial of basic human equality lockers
at pains to say that basic human
equality is a range property the
qualification for human equality is our
presence and a whole range of human
abilities and human attributes so some
are smarter than others some are bigger
some of our taller and is this isn't
passage passage eight though I have said
that all men by nature are equal I
cannot be supposed to understand all
sorts of equality age or virtue may give
me an adjust presidency excellency of
parts of merit may place others above
the common level yet all this consists
with the equality which all men are in
in respective jurisdiction or dominion
over one another the logic of that
position restricts what he can make our
husbands marginally greater strength the
greater natural strength of men such as
it is cannot possibly deprive women of
their basic title of equality for the
difference in strength or ability
between a husband and wife in any given
marriage is likely much smaller than
other the differences that we see all
over the human realm in defining basic
human equality many men are a blur and
stronger than other men but the norm of
basic equality applies among them so the
mere fact that have any given man and
woman that the man may be marginally
basic marginally stronger and a blur is
not going to refute the position on
basic equality set out in passage in
passage eight so i think this assertion
about husbands outrageous though it is
as a sideshow and we should look instead
to what he says about motherhood for
that is where the real action that is
where the real action is so let's talk a
little bit about motherhood and
pregnancy according to lock least one
modern commentator has tried to relate
the if the passage and passage six to
the issue of pregnancy she says it's a
woman's continual pregnancy that makes
the man by comparison a blur and
stronger is this right well what Locke
says about pregnancy doesn't license
this conclusion to the extent that women
are
continually pregnant he sees this as a
ground of obligation on men that's the
implication of passage 5 and there's
also an intriguing argument in the first
treatise about the pain and debilitation
of pregnancy our old friend Robert
filmer had argued that God gave Adam
authority over Eve when they were both
being punished in the fall in the
sentence that he pronounced in Genesis
316 this's you'll see the sentence at
the bottom and a footnote on page 3 of
the handout God is supposed to have said
unto the woman he said I will greatly
multiply thy sorrow and thy conception
in sorrow thou shalt bring forth
children and thy desire shall be to thy
husband and he shall rule over thee now
Locke's account of this passage is
complicated one thing he says is that
the subordination of Eve can be read
here as a prediction rather than as a
prescription rather than as a normative
prescription that's what he says in
passage 11 excuse me in passage 10 God
in this text gives not any authority to
Adam or Eve or two men over their wives
but I need for towels what should be the
wounds lot that's a that's a little bit
of a strained reading and he does
scramble back to the suggestion that
there is I grant a foundation in nature
for men's superiority in marriage but
then he says interesting things about
the contingency of the whole business
using an analogy with childbirth though
Genesis 316 predicts pain in childbirth
in sorrow thou shalt bring forth
children it does not lock says or lock
implies in prohibit anesthetics and
similarly Locke says in the condemnation
of Eve to being ruled by her husband
read passage 11 but there is here no
more law to oblige a woman to such
subjection if the circumstances either
of her conditional contract with her
husband should exempt her from it then
there is that she should bring forth
their children and sorrow and pain if
they could be found a remedy for it tree
ghing analogy
yeah and aesthetics as a analog to
equality seems to me that you cannot
read this as saying that the destiny of
women is subordination on account of
pregnancy whether such subordination
obtains in any particular case is
entirely a matter of circumstances and
consent certainly lock rejects any view
of women as mayor breeding machines such
ideas he condemns as morally hideous he
cites a traveler's account of the
practices of the Peruvians in this
regard apologies to any Peruvians in the
audience where he says in passage 12
they made their captives their
mistresses and choice Lee nourish the
children they had by them till about 13
years old they butchered and eat them
and they served the mothers after the
same fashion when they grew past
childbearing and ceased to bring them
anymore roasters locks cited this as an
obvious incident of a wicked custom in
his attack on innate moral ideas not
only is there no textual support in lot
for the thesis that the biology and
social exigencies of pregnancy
determined the social subordination of
women but I suspect that precisely the
opposite is the case the thesis I'm
arguing for is not simply that lock
didn't think that the fact of motherhood
undermined equality I think on the
contrary he used motherhood as a sort of
Trojan horse against his opponents
commitment to inequality it's actually
on the basis of motherhood that lock
destroys any differential political
claims based on paternity so let's look
at a couple of his motherhood arguments
in the first treatise fatherhood and the
rights of fatherhood a key to the system
that lot opposes no one is born free Sid
filmer God has provided authority to
rule over every person at every stage of
existence Adam apart each person is born
in subjection to his father says filmer
and God has explicitly commanded and the
fifth commandment that they should honor
the subjection by accepting their
fathers King like Authority
now there's all sorts of things Locke
wants to say about this position he asks
inconvenient questions about how one
gets from the intimate relation of
father and child to the relationship
between a king and the millions of his
subjects and he wants to give his own
account of the nature of parental
authority something that has very little
in common with political authority but
has to do with bringing the child up
into a position of full equality can't
go into that he'll votes of fascinating
discourse on children's rights for one
of the most striking things about
Locke's argument about the upbringing of
children is his insistence on the rights
and authority of mothers we hear this
first in an argument about procreation
responding to a claim by filmer that the
man is the nobler and principal agent in
the generation of children man the
nobler and principal agent and the
generation of children's is locked in
section thin passage 13-man the nobler
and the principal-agent what father when
he begets a child thinks further than
satisfying his present appetite if any
rights are to be based on the making of
a child you know like the investment of
labor and the labor theory of property
if any rights it would be based on the
making of a child they are mothers
rights passage 14 the women has an equal
share if not the greater as nourishing
the child a long time and her own body
out of her own substance there it is
fashioned and from her receives the
materials and principles of its
constitution not only that but in
passage 15 he adds a remarkable argument
about the insolvent of the fetus it is
so hard to imagine that the rational
soul should presently inhabit the yet
unformed embryo as soon as the father
has done his part in the act of
generation that effort that's the
insolvent is supposed to derive anything
from the parents that must certainly owe
most to the mother it's rejecting the
idea of insolvent at conception
insisting that in solvent happens during
the course of pregnancy it's not
intended to establish anything like an
abortion right though I guess it follows
from what Locke says that there is a
time after conception while the embryo
is being nourished in the mother's body
before it is in sold
so that its destruction might be a
different matter than the destruction of
a human person and like also thought
intriguingly me has so much to say on
these matters that it was an open
question whether a fetus counted as a
human life you see in passage 16 if it
comes in question whether the embryo in
an egg before incubation be alive or no
it's easy to perceive that a clear
distinct settled idea does not always
accompany the use of so known a word as
that of life is which seems to me to be
a reasonably sensible thing to say on
the matter actually makes a number of
observations about fetuses one in his
argument about personal identity which
says is the fetus that Waldron was in
1953 the same as the young infant that
Waldron was in 1956 and the professor
that Waldron is in 2010 is that the same
person all the way through by the same
token you might say that Socrates
Pontius Pilate Cesare Borgia and so on
are the same person he makes arguments
about the receptivity of about fetal
receptivity by sensors in the womb in
the course of his argument against
innate ideas and he makes some arguments
about oddly shaped fetuses monstrous
deformed fetuses and their relationship
to the formal definitions of the human
species all that is very interesting but
for our purposes it's the emphatic
egalitarianism or even the favoring of
mothers that's the interesting thing
about the passage whatever obligation
nature and the right of generation lays
on children it must certainly bind them
equally to both the concurrent causes of
it now that argument so far is basically
what we would call a natural law
argument trying to look at nature and
discern some normative consequences from
what happens as a result of various
causes but lock does also concentrate on
filmers scriptural case pulling filmer
up short again and again and again at
every mention of the fifth commandment
honor thy father says filmer there's a
basis for kingly Authority honor thy
father says lock that's not a reason
it's a half reason and if you count the
other
friesen honor thy mother the bottom
falls out of filmers argument it's an
obvious enough point unlock drivers at
home quite well and by my count and ten
different passages in the first treatise
and seven different passages in the
Second Treatise the Bible says honor thy
father says filming and mother says lock
yes yes yes yes sis filmer but it does
certainly say honor thy father and
mother says lock yeah but certainly God
has commanded us to honor our father and
mother says like and it just happens
again and again and again and it's not
just the commandment and Exodus in one
section I've set that out I'm certainly
not going to read it out section 18 you
have locked her in to the trouble of
citing 13 distinct biblical passages
containing all sorts of respect for the
rights of mothers 13 biblical passages
including two from the New Testament
which lock hardly ever sites and what
he's saying is had our author that's
filmer sat down this command without
gobbling as God gave it and joined
mother to father every reader would have
seen that it was so far from
establishing the monarchic or power of
the Father that it set up the mother
equal with him and enjoying nothing but
was what was due in common to both
father and mother for that is the
constant tenor of Scripture he goes on
and gives us whole list of occurrences
and over the page at the end of passage
18 he says the rule is children obey
your parents and I do not remember any
where I read children obey your father
and no more the scripture joins mother
too and that homage which is due from
children may the scripture makes the
authority of father and mother so equal
that in some places it neglects even the
priority of order which is thought due
to the father and the mother has put
first and locked concludes from which so
constantly joining father and mother
together we may conclude that the honor
they have to a title from their children
is one common right belonging equally to
them both filmer is trying to walk the
sacred word of god to make it comply
with his present purposes
I suppose it's possible to argue that
he's just doing this strategically he's
just using the and mother refrained to
embarrass filmer marybeth an orphan says
that lock used women to score debating
points against Robert filmer the idea is
that he would say anything betray any
part of his own convictions including
his own fundamental sexism in order to
discredit filmers argument and certainly
is true that the passages are ad hominem
they are intended to embarrass Robert
filmer they are intended to show and you
see this in 21 they're almost a sort of
a reductio ad absurdum that people like
filmer would find the consequence that
women have equal power observed would
have shown the absurdity of the supposed
absolute power of over children had been
if it'd been called parental rather than
paternal and discovered that it belonged
to the mother to four it will but very
ill serve the turn of those men who
contend so much for absolute power of
fatherhood that the mother should have
any share in it so the idea is filmer
and his cronies are certainly going to
be embarrassed by any matriarchy
conclusion but john locke himself had no
difficulty with the notion of a queen
though he regarded the whole idea of
absolute monarchy as pernicious he
accepted constitutional monarchy as a
possibility not only that but a
proposition that he goes on to use in
the same passage to further embarrass
the film Arians that it would have but L
supported the monarchy that they contend
for that fundamental authority should be
placed not on one button to persons
jointly is a position he himself
embraced he actually travelled back from
exile in Holland to England with the
woman who was to become the jointly
ruling Queen Mary of William and Mary
after the glorious after the Glorious
Revolution and he was associated
explicitly with that part of the
constitutional settlement of 1689 that
there would be two monarchs one man and
one woman ruling ruling in England so
for love it's not an absurdity for his
opponents it's an absurdity so he's it's
a reduction to absurdity in their eyes
but it's an ad hominem reductio rather
than a equivocal reductio at any rate
lock is in no position to simply put
down again the position that he has
taken up to refute filmer and it's not a
position that he wants to put down we
the the claims he makes about mothers
rights are not only key to his
refutation of filmers particular
patriarchal ism but major staging points
in his argument for basic human equality
they hook up with some quite
extraordinary theories on theorems on
the Equality of men and women they are
in effect pioneering moves in locks
progress to a more comprehensive
egalitarianism so for example lockers
and this is passage 23 lock is perfectly
happy to associate his fifth commandment
argument with the premise of basic
equality that he uses throughout his
theory so in passage 23 if fathers by be
getting their children acquire no such
power over them and if the command honor
thy father and mother give it not but
only and joins a duty owing to parents
equally where the subjects are not into
the mother as well as the father if all
this be so as I think then man has a
natural freedom notwithstanding all that
our author that's filmer confidently
says to the contrary since all that
share and the same common nature
faculties and powers are in nature equal
and ought to partake in the same common
rights and privileges till the manifest
appointment of God who is lord over all
blessed forever can be produced to show
any particular person supremacy or until
a man's own consent subjects him to a
superior now it's a very important
passage sounds abstract very important
passage because it's explicitly
associating what he's been doing with
the fifth commandment to the
foundational claims of basic political
equality that are indispensable to the
affirmative theory of government that is
setting up in the in the second in the
second treatise
I've emphasized that lock does nothing
with this thesis of the husband being
the a blur and the stronger in marriage
rest nothing on it doesn't exploit it
doesn't use it to leverage anything else
but he does use the Equality of men and
women for one further point in relation
to Parenthood not only does he say that
women are men's equals in the upbringing
of children and in the obligation that
children Oh to their parents he also
insists that if the man runs off or is
killed or otherwise disappears from the
picture women are perfectly capable of
discharging the obligations of
parenthood so there's a long suggestion
that that there's no obligation on the
woman to try to find an uncle of some
sort or a male guardian to do the
politically important task for example
of bringing up sons the way the Pateman
and others have read this is that the
account of education and upbringing is a
very masculinist one the transmission of
masculine authority from father to son
but lock makes it patently clear in
passages that I really didn't have a
whole lot of time to go through this
afternoon but you'll see some of them in
24 and 25 where lock indicates that even
where they're not going to be two
presents parents present single
motherhood is a perfectly reasonable
basis for the upbringing of children and
in this case the mother will have all
the authority such as it is that any
parent male or female has over their
offspring there are other passages we
could go on and on their passages where
lot suggests that women are much more
constant in the defense and upbringing
of the young than men are if any parent
is likely to run off its most likely to
be the man man seems to have a premium
not only being a blur and stronger but
marginally less responsible in their in
their behavior and anyway that's the
case for Locke as a theorist of gender
equality that's the case for motherhood
as the idea that takes them in this
direction I know that many of my
colleagues particularly my feminist
colleagues and political theory remains
to call about this interpretation
skeptical in a way that may indicate
there's something wrong with even trying
to do what I've been doing in this
lecture I wonder why this is I suspect
it's the idea that we want to be able to
use 17th century figures as exemplars of
contemporary sexism to remind us of how
sexist for example 17th century society
is and possibly even 21st century
society living under the shadow of locks
constitutionalism there's an assumption
that we must be able to charge people
like John Locke with sexism that we must
be able to assume that of course he is
guilty that we must be delighted to find
the one or two passages that support
this interpretation lock being
inconsistent like every other
philosopher on earth yeah and we must
there must be some explanation for the
discomfort or refusal to look at the
very substantial evidence on the other
side so I you know my question is why
not portray lock and use lock as the
proto feminist he was at least on the
evidence I've presented is it anything
to do with motherhood one feminist
scholar I greatly respect Carol Sanger
has argued that late 20th century
feminism has had a difficult time coming
to terms with motherhood as though
motherhood was always there waiting to
be used to subvert gender equality and
so people are very nervous about a
philosopher special email philosophy
speaking about the nature obligations
and privileges of motherhood and that
means that locks use of it in the other
direction is disconcerting it throws us
off balance so to speak I think there's
something to about the way we read the
Canon of political theory the sort of
thing that you've been doing for the
last semester and we'll carry on doing
in the spring sometimes we're in danger
of reading it less for ideas that may
change or influence our thinking then
reading it has confirmation of the
existence of prejudices that we want to
take issue with it seems as though no
one wants to be challenged by a text
anymore or to learn anything intriguing
from it
as opposed to learning anything about it
that we didn't know before it's true
that no writer is ever entirely free of
his centuries prejudice not locked in
the 17th century not you not me in the
21st century but there are sometimes
more things in these texts than are
dreamed off in our preconceptions I
think we sell ourselves short and we may
be selling the moral imagination short
if we are not open to things in an
author's writing even in the writing of
a dead white moderate respectable male
if we are not open to things in an
author's writing that may have offended
or startled his contemporaries and may
shock us to by anticipating positions
that we thought were all our own so
that's what I wanted to say about Locke
and motherhood thank you very much
indeed thank you
microphone there and one over there
hi my name's Gavin McGowan him sophomore
in the college thanks very much for your
lecture I just had a question about one
of your last points um if you talked
about the nervousness of late 20th
century early 21st century feminism of
basing of talking about motherhood I
just wanted to ask isn't this to a
certain extent an understandable
nervousness because you go from if you
say base equality gender equality on on
a position that people hold in a
conjugal relation for the sake of
raising children that might be seen as
viewing quite close to a normative claim
that therefore you should be in this
conjugal relation with a man and you
should be raising children so I just
wanted to say that your song doesn't now
that's a very good point and and I I
mean I think I accept that it is partly
the lock seems to imply that raising
children are sort of destiny for men and
for women and the obligations that it
generates equally incumbent on both at
it's plain that he's not anticipating
the position that we take which is the
position that the raising of children is
utterly optional and the people although
he himself never married he wasn't in
holy orders he hung around with a number
of very powerful and influential women
but he never married but never that
never mind that you're absolutely right
that the the one danger of this position
is that taking motherhood as the key to
equal political responsibility seems to
make it doesn't necessarily make
equality conditional on that but it does
seem to give some normative privileges
to the whole business of conceiving and
raising children yeah
yes
my friend answer is that I don't know it
obviously be a sensible thing to do yeah
I'm sorry the thing was on the on the
use of the word man the stuff that I
talked about at the beginning since the
biblical passages were written
originally in Hebrew has anybody looked
into the the Hebrew medium it's a very
very important point and I I should have
done something I'm sure something has
been done it hasn't percolated through
in the way that would suggest it
decisively settles anything and I think
it's a fact that many languages and
probably Hebrew is among them Mike I
don't know whether you know they do have
a generic term for human being that does
also can also have the narrow usage so
my hunch is that the Hebrew by itself
simply as a matter of vocabulary doesn't
settle the matter and that one has to
look at the at the the text and the
context and the particular argument and
this particular reflection on the
argument in order to get the in order to
get the conclusion so it's I mean the
moment you mentioned it maybe it became
clear to me that this is something that
one ought to look into what Locke is
doing is not so much meditating on the
the Hebrew word as noticing that the
hebrew word is associated with a plural
pronoun so man as a safe let us make man
and let us give them authority over the
whole world and that association of the
word man with the plural pronoun is is
certainly in the Hebrew original and
that's what lockers exploiting this was
spoken to them who is them Adam and Eve
the reference of them must be the same
as the reference of man and man and so
on so it's that contextual relational
aspect that he talks about
either way either way there's no
egalitarians that the word for God is in
the plural yes
yes it's pot yes it's possible I'm sorry
I'll restate the question it seems like
many of the arguments that I pointed out
seem if anything to give greater
authority and greater power to women
than two men so if I understood the
question maybe some of what he says
about the man being a blur and the
stronger is are sort of a corrective to
try to redress the equilibrium in the
picture it's it's interesting what lock
doesn't do is what his near contemporary
thomas hobbes did which is to claim that
women are much more powerful than men
because mothers commonly have the power
the physical power if they will to
strangle their newborn children and so
since they allow their newborn children
to live out of the kindness of their
hearts the children are in some sort of
relationship of despotic all subjection
to their mothers who could yeah and I
mean Hobbs is wonderful on what was that
Hobbes had a very good sense of humor
but in his discussion of despotism the
despotism of mothers is the the more
powerful thing my impression although
it's an intriguing hypothesis is that
there's no evidence that lock was trying
to use the problematic passage six to
redress some equi librium he is
certainly is producing arguments which
if anything sway the balance in favor of
the rights of mothers and I think we
just had to let that lie let it stand as
it is rather than to say that he was
trying to do some sort of precise
titration or calibration to to rejet
redress the matters does John Locke
elaborate on what he means by a blur and
stronger in passage six because to me it
seems like there's a tendency to
correlate a blur and stronger with
better yes yes I don't think so I'm
stronger there's no particular reason
why that would go with better and a blur
there is a reason why it would go with
better the way that I read what he says
in the past he does no further
elaboration as I said it's a throwaway
line it's there we have to look at it
but he doesn't do any elaboration of it
or any hard
work on it what he does say is that
basic human equality is consistent with
differences in ability consistent with
differences in virtue consistent in
differences of strength and that's the
the general position that is actually
quite close to this passage in terms of
its location in the Second Treatise so
as I said since he is committed to the
view that all these differences are
consistent with basic equality it's
clear that whatever he's saying about
the wife subordination to the husband on
the basis of this marginal difference
cannot be conceived as overturning the
basic equality but there's no doubt that
he thinks there are important
differences of ability among human
beings and so when he develops his
theory of representation when it
develops his theory of the social
contract and how we choose our
governor's he believes that these are
differences that we should certainly pay
attention to not that any given man is
to be preferred to any given woman but
that we should certainly look at whoever
is being considered for their political
strengths and their moral abilities
thank you yep does this work okay just a
quick question um is it possible to
restate locks position without assuming
the normativity of scripture for the
individual and for society yes yes and
no I think would be the honest answer
certainly it is remarkable that the most
powerful part of his case for equality
is in this little-known passage about
the image of God in in the first
treatise and just as there is a
suggestion and modern theories of human
dignity and modern theories of human
rights that there is a powerful sort of
biblical underpinning for that to be
found in the notion of imago Dei image
of God and that that does hook human
dignity human rights claims to a
theological foundation lock seems to be
perfectly willing to welcome that now
when it comes to the Second Treatise
the argument seems to proceed on a non
scriptural foundation so he gives his
account of basic human equality he says
look we're all endowed with roughly the
same faculties roughly the same
abilities roughly the same human nature
we are capable of understanding the
existence of God we are presently sent
by God into the world about his business
for his purposes not one another's
purposes we are not made for each
other's uses as the inferior animals are
made for hours and so very very
beginning of the Second Treatise you
have a strong religious but non
scriptural argument so it's one of those
cases where you know how sometimes
people say well natural or arguments are
supposed to parallel scriptural
arguments but it doesn't mean that
secular arguments parallel scriptural
arguments the the argument can be non
scriptural but still be religious in its
in its formulation so my view is that
Locke never gives up the religious side
of his convictions about equality and I
argued in that book that Michael was
good enough to mention God lock and
equality that the case for fundamental
human equality the case for being
willing to blur your eyes over these
evident differences in capacities and
say still there's something
fundamentally the same about all human
beings that case is inseparable from
some theological convictions but i
believe it is separable from
specifically scriptural convictions one
more sir
yeah we have to say and I wish I didn't
but we have to say that approach I'm
sorry I'm sorry the question is about
passage six if you remember in passage
sex that says what you're going to have
a decision power somewhere it naturally
force to the man's share and the
question was well what's the force of
naturally there does it just mean
naturally as an it's obvious or doesn't
mean naturally as it everybody sees its
conventional or does it mean naturally
as its biological or normatively arising
out of human nature as far as I can tell
lock does mean that it arises out of
natural differences something like
biological differences between between
men and women may be the biological
differences that make us attend to
differences in sporting events for men's
teams and women's teams but it's pretty
clear that he's I mean I'm not saying
that the whole passage is carefully
drafted or formulated but I think
naturally there is doing recognizable
naturalistic work and the only reason I
say that was it when he was talking
about that other passage from Genesis 3
16 about pain and childbirth and
subjection to your husband he grudgingly
put it in a parenthesis and I concede
there is a foundation in nature for it
so it seems to me that he's reflecting
on the fact that of the greater bodily
strength of men whether a black needs to
be interpreted in any way that goes
beyond that to mean for example morally
a blur or a blur as a matter of
intellectual power is a further question
a blur and stronger could just mean able
to lift things able to hammer nails and
or something like that but it's a
problematic passage but i'm sure the
naturally is meant naturalistically okay
well I really want to thank professor
Waldron again for coming giving us an
extremely stimulating lecture but you
should remember when we get it we all
get to lock it in a few weeks so don't
forget thanks very much
you